training camp for the raiders begins in  three weeks from today that's when  rookies report a couple of days after  that the veterans will show up in  henderson minicamp went well for the  raiders there were no major headlines  coming out of camp which is just how you  like it really the new guys are all  getting ready to know each other we  talked to quarterback derek carr today  and there's no question with a new head  coach and new system the raiders have a  lot of work to do  it's a new it's a new culture it's a new  way of doing things so we got a lot of  way to go i mean we got a lot of talent  i've been on some really talented teams  that didn't do much and so you know just  the leadership part of it just making  sure that the work is being put in  before this i was  up early throwing with you know today  this morning you know we're working on  our craft and we're working on getting  better and